we've killed people through our
intelligence services to protect
National Security interests have people
been killed was it legal don't know but
it should be investigated
people don't understand that you know if
if there is indeed this incredible
awesome technology that is being
secreted by the US government if that's
true
I'm not justifying this but I would
certainly as a security official be
trying to protect that secret to stop
the Russians and the Chinese from
getting access to it are you afraid for
your life no no not all I mean I accept
that I'm probably under surveillance
um I know that I am at times uh but
um you haven't been told hey stop
talking about it or some men in black or
some other no no no and I I think they
know I would go public if they did
I mean I I at the moment any threat like
that emerged I'd make my dentist to make
sure the world knew about it so no
intimidation no harassment no but the
witnesses that I'm talking to have been
intimidated they have been harassed and
they've been told on some occasions that
they would be murdered if they spoke out
about it I imagine grass is afraid
probably he feels good that he feels
like he's doing the right thing I don't
know I don't know how that works neither
do I
neither do I my friend yeah you just
watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy